building machines of war in what used to
be a shoe factory just two months ago
Artyom Dima and Maxine made Footwear in
this Kiev workshop then they switched to
munitions Artyom used 3d computer models
to develop these mounting brackets for
Kalashnikovs the boys at the front and
with these brackets for various
applications but especially to attach a
scope we've designed several versions
even for grenade launchers these are not
toys they're made for war the men don't
build actual weapons here but the parts
they make are vital for weapon precision
this order is bound for the front just
how many parts are inside the shipment
is a secret a few kilometers away we
visit a warehouse on the city's edge
this is where Kalashnikov brackets and
various other goods come before they're
distributed to soldiers anna is a
coordinator here every three days she
says someone from the front comes to
pick up supplies bags boots warm
underwear helmets bulletproof vests and
packages with food and medicine items
that should be supplied by the
government but instead are financed by
donations both from Ukraine and abroad
sometimes the goods are old and
substandard the volunteers say these do
more harm than good I feel guilty about
the soldiers who have died or are dying
because of bad provisions the ones were
fighting and depending on our help in
the meantime we've had to borrow so much
money that some of us are close to
bankruptcy but people keep helping us
around town it's now common to see
people out collecting money for
Ukraine's army an army that critics say
could hardly win a war because it's
fighting with equipment that dates as
far back as World War two
that's exactly the problem facing the
Ukrainian forces quality Gansa that
don't shoot straight bulletproof vests
that are Abdullah proof and uniforms
that are not warm enough for winter
conditions